o pessoal de 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer um carrinho utilizando materiais
recicláveis como vocês podem ver e
espinhos se movimenta com a ajuda de uma
elas nem amanhã
o projeto está incluído primeiro vamos
ter uma garrafa de plástico duas tampas
um x-ato então uma faca que vocês vão
utilizar para fazer estas aberturas no
centro das tampas precisar de um clipe
ou então um pedaço de arame movem o
pedaço eram tiverem do modo indicado vi
em seguida encaixem morango por dentro
das tampas feijão com as partilhas
contatos no centro
depois tem que dobrar oran a parte de
sobra do lado esquerdo modo que vocês
depois consigam aprendeu com colo e vejo
também que aquela parte fica do outro
lado da tampa fica por veicular é a
parta reta também se vocês quiserem
podem colocar o tempo para preparar
aquela geringonça agora precisar de uma
bolinha do sul
se vocês não tiverem podem usar é um
pedaço de caneta aí vocês concordam mas
somente como aqui mas claro não consigo
estar com a tesoura e salvar uma serra
daquelas frontal e pronto vai ser fácil
depois cortar agora vou fazer a abertura
por uma questão de estética e também
para ser fácil depois que se faça seria
quase impossível pois encaixar o
elástico lá dentro
se eu não fizer esta abertura
façam dois orifícios na parte de trás do
carro vão precisar de mais um pedaço do
irã móveis neste formato assim mais um
gol para dar energia ao nosso carinho e
vou precisar de ir lá e eu vou usar aqui
3 quanto mais melhor
depois que só voltará a tampa na ponta
da garrafa e por outro lado prender os
elásticos culpa da cerâmica que tomaram
mudar tem chance para aparecer só por um
crime de cola e por lá uma tampa
agora como é óbvio faltam nas obras e eu
fiz o mesmo procedimento para todas as
tampas e vejam que é bastante simples
encaixá-los o saque do pãozinho do
churrasco
então podem usar a mais grosso
[Música]
agora para lutar ou seja era o carnaval
daquela partida mas preciso de ela isso
para impulsionar o ar para trás de
ensino desse modo levar clarinha ao
andamento já que é bastante simples é só
cortar pois o circo em quarto parte e
tirar aquela ponta
[Música]
para finalizar vocês têm claro assim com
aquela inclinação celas e vocês podem
infectar com vocês quiserem que eu
queria aquela parte do rótulo mas depois
voltei colar por cá ficava mais bonito e
vejam agora o funcionamento seja róndon
só que o 300 tampas e grandes para
diminuir isso basta você usar um pouco
de desodorizante e pronto vai ficar bom
o atrito vai diminuir significativamente
vocês vão ver a diferença e claro se
vocês quiserem podem sempre visar um
tripulante o vosso caminho bastante
simples roubar algumas tampas e fazer
algo do gênero disto então pensei só os
pés no estado se vocês quiserem ajudar o
canal só deixar um lobby e se inscreveu
para acompanhar essas coisas que eu vou
fazer é isso também que tal é a minha